so i'm in the same boat uh the question
is directed towards you but i'll give
you my answer really quick
which is sean how do you balance side
hustles while performing at twitch
my answer to that and i've said it
before is um
i don't ballot i don't do anything on
the side um
and frankly i have no idea how you do it
our good friend ramon is able to do it
really well
i get some people can do it i personally
can't do it and i don't even try and uh
i'm not ashamed about that
yeah yeah there's different ways to like
kind of organize your time like you see
this from elon musk or jack dorsey
running
two multi-billion dollar public
companies at once as ceo right like kind
of a crazy thing that
kind of seemed impossible before and i
would say
i do it two ways one is i throw more
hours at it
so like i don't take weekends off like i
work seven days a week
i don't work all day all seven days a
week but i
my weekend is just like my weekday
they're the same construction so all of
a sudden i got an
extra 16 hours on the weekend where i
can do things
same thing at night like i don't watch a
bunch of like tv i stopped watching
like you know nba games stuff like that
like i basically was like look i can cut
that out
and that's two hours a night that
instead i can create content right
or like when i do the podcast everybody
else at the back when we started this
everybody would go down to the cafeteria
at twitch for lunch
i would walk across the street the
studio was your office was literally
like 50 steps away from
from twitch i would walk 50 steps away
go to the hustle office we would record
from 12 to 1.
everybody else has eaten lunch i'm
recording a podcast cool i'll eat lunch
on my desk
like later it doesn't matter right so
there's these little pockets of time you
can unlock
that's the first bit second bit is
hiring i bring on people so when i say
i'm doing x it's rarely just me doing x
it's like
ben or zack or romine or chris or i have
a whole bunch of people that
i say hey i'm doing this interesting
project who wants to do it with me
and they're like i find great people who
want to do interesting things together
and i say cool what's in it for you do
you want money do you want learning do
you want like
rep you don't want to build your network
what do you want out of this i'll make
sure you get it
and they let me like i said be in two
places at once
because i could be doing this and they
could be doing that what's your burn on
all the like because whenever i hear you
say you got all these people i'm like
damn
yeah that must be a lot uh monthly yes
my burn is expensive it's expensive but
the things now bring in money so it's
it's okay it offsets it
but like uh but the angel investing
doesn't bring in money and that's not
angel investing i don't pay salaries
it's only carry so it's splitting the
upside
so they have they they get they i took
some of my my 20
carry and i took it down and let them
have more carry
so um which you know for them is fine
because they make money doing other
things so they're like cool
this will pay off in five years that's
great and i get to like learn a bunch
about investing
i get to put together a portfolio so if
i want to go get a job doing this or i
want to start my own fund
i'll have a track record to point at and
say no i i did these investments before
i've been doing this for years
so that's kind of what's in it for them
um so i do have a you know significant
burn i would say it's like
200 to 300 000 a year of like people
cost to do these things
my goal is for them to break even but if
not like that's what money is for
money is to be invested in things that
will grow and so i kind of like just
look at it like an investment and
uh it's worked out so far where the side
hustles more than pay for
the money i put in um now the last thing
is basically
an acknowledgement and i talked i was
pretty transparent with the people at
twitch which was like
look i operate not on a nine to five
like
strict schedule like cool i'm just gonna
punch the clock for 40 hours a week no
no
uh i'm here to do this mission you want
this job done
great i'm gonna get that job done here's
the trade i
i can make sure this job gets done you
don't ask me how and when and where and
why and how you know like all the time
uh like not in such a like
confrontational way but like it's an
understood agreement like they know
what i do i'm very open about like hey i
have a podcast i have a
newsletter like the ceo of twitch
subscribes to the newsletter and like
will dm me about it like sometimes right
like
i'm not hiding any of these things they
know i do these things they know they
take some time
but they're okay with that trade because
i deliver the goods in my projects
and so uh my trainer told me this one
day because i told him i said i'm
feeling a little bit guilty like
you know i wonder i really like these
people i don't want them to feel like
i'm shortchanging them he goes well do
you deliver the goods
i was like well yeah like i perform like
they get the results they want
okay well you're that dude and i was
like what do you mean he's like he's
like they don't pay you to sit in your
chair for certain hours they pay you to
deliver the results
and so just make sure you deliver the
results and if you're delivering the
results in less time that's because
you're that dude maybe not everybody
could do that but you could do that
and i was like oh man what a pep talk
that was uh you know made me feel good
about something that i was feeling
you know uncertain about or uneasy about
before and you're on paternity leave now
right
yeah so that helps too yeah exactly
yes and that's you know like big
companies understand like look you
if you have a kid my first kid i only
took 10 days off
which i really regret i should have uh i
should have took the whole leave and so
this time i decided i'd make i'm gonna
make sure i take some off
and this time my family actually really
needs me there whereas the first time i
was like i don't know what the hell i'm
gonna do here
uh my wife's kind of got it under
control let me go back to work
and so this time i kind of realized that
the idea of like oh this project is so
important and like
if i take this time off then you know
let me do it i'll take time off later
and
later never came and that was a big
lesson for me like
don't don't put important things off
till later do them now
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
travel never looking back